monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
j'aimerais que nous puissions nous en
tenir ou fait parce que les questions
d'actualité justement c'est à ça elles
servent le 1er mai plusieurs dizaines de
manifestants certains par effraction ont
pénétré dans l'enceinte de l'hôpital de
la pitié salpêtrière pour échapper aux
gaz lacrymogènes
cette irruption dans un lieu de soins
étaient de nature à susciter une
légitime émotion
heureusement aucune agression ne semble
avoir été commise et les manifestants
n'ont apparemment pas pénétrer dans les
bâtiments
je veux d'ailleurs ici salué le sang
froid le calme et le formidable
professionnalisme des personnels de
santé pour maintenir les patients à
l'abri de cette agitation qui a fait
peur
hélas on ne peut pas dire que le
gouvernement et fait preuve du même sang
froid
si l'on en juge par ces déclarations on
a attaqué un hôpital on a agressé son
personnel soignant c'est unir une
intrusion violente
avez-vous dit successivement monsieur le
ministre c'est un acte scandaleux
avez vous ajouté monsieur le premier
ministre c'est une exactions
inqualifiables et indigne d'après la
ministre de la santé
quant au président de l'assistance
publique l'ancien ministre le guen
il a ajouté c'est un acte de pure
barbarie
alors monsieur le ministre sur quels
faits le gouvernement s'est-il fondé
pour donner l'alarmé français sur des
violences qui n'ont pas eu lieu
que s'est il passé exactement à la pitié
salpêtrière le 1er mai et si vous avez
été induit en erreur par de fausses
informations
conséquence en avez-vous tiré à paroles
et au ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs ces
termes monsieur le président philippe
bas est important effectivement de
regarder les faits l'ensemble des faits
sur le périmètre en question de
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière
il trouve que une partie des
manifestants n'a pas emprunté le
parcours prévu et qu'une partie des
manifestants a traversé par la rue
jeanne-d'arc et a bloqué de fait la tête
du cortège qui étaient ouverts gelé
précisait tout à l'heure par des forces
de sécurité comme de façon
traditionnelle
et à ce moment là il ya eu un certain
nombre de eur un certain nombre d heures
assez violent ils ont débuté dès 14h30
sur ce site
puis nous avons pu assister à une
attaque ou un commissariat pris pour
cible avec la des images très claires de
violence contre ce commissariat avec la
volonté d'y pénétrer il était 15h47
à 16h01 monsieur le président certains
casseurs ont tenté de s'introduire dans
une école primaire là encore vous avez
pu voir notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux le témoignage de la responsable
du site qui a témoigné sur cela à 16h47
un crs est tombé évacué par ses
camarades sous les cris je les râper
d'achever le sur le boulevard de
l'hôpital il a été traîné jusqu'à
l'hôpital et dans ce créneau là il y a
eu deux effractions une par l'entrée
principale une part l'entrée secondaire
et les images ont montré notamment trois
individus qui ont su surmonter une
grille qui est à plus de trois mètres de
haut qui ont ensuite ouvert cette grille
en faisant casser la chaîne et le la
serrure dudit portail et sont rentrés
dans le lieu quand je me suis rendu sur
place pour aller visiter le crs et
prendre des nouvelles de sa santé je
n'étais pas informé de cette intrusion
par contre les responsables hospitaliers
qui m'ont accueilli m'ont fait part de
leur émotion
et c'est sur la base de leurs émotions
qui d'ailleurs été filmée par les
chaînes d'information que je me suis
prononcé et c'est sur la base de cette
émotion extrêmement forte que j'ai
dénoncé ces faits parce que monsieur
philippe bas vous le savez j'avais je
crois dans l'histoire d'une
manifestation
on a eu ce genre de situation où on a pu
successivement attaqué un commissariat
une école et
entrés de force puisqu'il ya eu bris de
ces ruraux condensé l'hôpital c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai utilisé ce mot
qui au vu des événements le lendemain
mais surtout au vu de la polémique qui
ont été menées et qui mettait du coup en
cause la qualité exceptionnelle du
travail de nos forces de sécurité
j'ai souhaité faire évoluer le mot en
prenant celui de la directrice et donc
d'évoquer une intrusion